Greece is running out of money again
while the new Prime Minister is trying
to convince Europe the country will pay
its debts Greek citizens aren't as
confident bank deposits in Greece of
tanked it would seem that individuals
and corporations aren't sure their money
is safe in the bank and are depositing
it abroad or stuffing their mattresses
private banks aren't the only
institution struggling to stay solvent
the Greek state owes a lot of money
Greece's debt as a percentage of GDP is
huge near one hundred and eighty percent
by far the highest in the eurozone
making it worse Greece's GDP is falling
again after a brief uptick and
unemployment has stopped improving the
economy had a period of improvement in
2014 but the election of a new
government has given the financial
markets the jitters jitters that can be
seen in the yield of the ten-year Greek
government bond yields started rising
again last year and that indicates
investors are less confident that Greece
will be able to pay off its debt over
the long term so who pays if Greece does
default European governments will take
the biggest hit they own 62 percent of
Greece's debt the private sector claims
17 percent and the IMF 10 percent all
could lose billions if Greece doesn't
pay back its loans